foreign
Capital spring has redefined how a sky
Terrace can be effectively integrated
into a skyscraper not just as Greenery
in the sky but is a true extension of
Social and Community spaces from the
ground
capita spring is a 51 store remake
development it is located right in the
middle of CBD Capital spring has a
number of key features chief of which
are the number of green spaces which is
available in the building for everybody
to enjoy
we had a very clear brief laying out the
technical requirements for the project
essentially the central business
district over the years had become a
place that was really only occupied from
nine to five and there was a strong
desire to create a development that went
beyond the typical Tower but that
actually could become a catalyst for the
Rejuvenation of the downtown area
the spaces in between each of these
different components is populated with
the social spaces of the project so an
18 meter high city room at the base that
is a community node for the surrounding
residents of the CBD the midsection of
the tower is occupied by a 30 meter high
jungle space connected by a continuous
spiral of activities from live work and
play and at the rooftop a continuous
loop of urban farms and garden spaces
integrated with FNB establishments the
whole tower has a unifying gesture of a
Sleek pinstripe facade that is then
pulled open to reveal the social and
green spaces of the development so in a
way a tower that combines both Sleek
modernity with tropical urbanism
a lot of tourists coming up over here
and this is like a must-see stop to
Singapore it is now very popular in the
social media on Instagram and everybody
has made it a point to come out here and
take a look and enjoy the Singapore city
skyline
one of the things I really love about
the project is the way the facades work
both inside out and outside in so
they're not only something that
beautifies the the tower it reframes my
experiences of the city and has given me
a new perspective of the the urbanism of
downtown Singapore and Beyond
well my dad is Singaporean and I grew up
in Singapore so it's been an incredible
privilege and honor to be a part of
shaping the future of the the cityscape
and the public realm in Singapore
[Music]